une image choc quittent le site vite
c'est l'un des 10 commandements inscrits
sur huit cent mille tapis de souris qui
vont être distribués à des élèves de cm2
la campagne de prévention est lancée par
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
elle est destinée à inculquer aux jeunes
internautes les règles de prudence
nécessaire face aux dangers de la toile
hélène drouet
depuis le début de l'année l'association
un clic déclic fait le tour de france
des collèges pour expliquer aux jeunes
les règles d'internet parmi les
premières consignes la prudence sur les
sites de discussions virtuelles et chat
les enfants entrent souvent en contact
avec des personnes qu'ils ne connaissent
absolument pas
pierre
c'est pas trop les dangers quoi balles
et les pédophiles tous ceux qui aiment
chat c'est avec nous pour après ce mardi
rendez vous je connaissais un peu et
après je aujourd'hui j'ai appris un peu
plus c'est un peu confus notre choix que
je pensais que mais la méfiance
n'empêche pas les dérives en effet 17 %
des jeunes de 11 à 17 ans ont déjà été
confrontés sur internet à des contenus
violents ou pornographiques
pour sensibiliser ces jeunes l'éducation
nationale lance donc aujourd'hui une
campagne intitulée sur la toile méfie
toi des pièges 800000 tapis de souris
vont être distribués dans les classes de
cm2 avec des messages de prévention tels
que n'accepte aucun rendez-vous jamais
une opération réalisée en partenariat
avec des associations héros avec les
actions à l'enfant s'il n'est pas
informée a tendance à croire tout ce
qu'on lui dit donc si on lui dit si il
est en train dans les charts devra
parler faire une rencontre avec
quelqu'un qui justement m le roller
comme lui il risque de lui donner rendez
vous et c'est déjà arrivé et ça arrive
et ça c'est dangereux il existe pourtant
des moyens pour protéger ses enfants des
logiciels de contrôle parental peuvent
être téléchargés gratuitement
ils empêchent notamment aux enfants de
transmettre leur adresse ou leur numéro
de téléphone
à la doller